メロディー  （～♪Happy Birthday to you♪～）
フーー！
パン!!（クラッカー）
おめでと～～～～!!!!!
拍手（ﾊﾟﾁﾊﾟﾁ）
皆様、誕生日！祝ってますか？
とういうわけで誕生日祝う時に
皆さんはケーキに年の数だけローソクを立てると思います
僕は今、23歳なのでろうそくを23本立てました
で、電気を消して、フーっと消して
誕生日おめでとうと
よく分からないんですけど祝いますね。
で、僕思ったんですけども、
この誕生日を祝うローソクを消す作業というのは、
と僕は思いました
年が増えてくにつれてローソクが増えていくので
ひょっとしたら、100歳になると消せないかもしれない
はたして、
検証やっていきたいと思います
だから、ひと吹きじゃないと…
はたして何本のローソクまで、
僕はひと吹きでローソクの火を全部消すことが出来るだろう？
今回、検証していきたいと思います
では行こう！！！！！！！！！！！！
次は30歳でやってみましょう
はい、ということで30本のローソクが準備できました
30歳の誕生日でございます
みなさん、おめでとうございます
ありがとうございます
おめでとうございますっと
いらっしゃいませ（？）
♪～
Happy Birthday Dear 俺！
Happy Birthday to you~
フーッ！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！
（クラッカー）
っしゃー！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！
っしゃ！！
おめでとう！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！
これぐらいはいけますわな
30歳までは、多分全然普通に祝えると思います
次ちょっと飛ばして50歳行ってみましょう
♪～
はい、というわけで50歳の誕生日です
ありがとうございます
みなさんほんとにね、これまでありがとう
いらっしゃいませ（？）
♪～
まてまて、そろそろ火事じゃない？　カメラ）w
そろそろ火事だよね
Happy Birthday to you
ッフーー！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！！
おめでとう!!!!!!!!
っしゃー！よっしゃー！！
いけるもんだね！いけるね！
次は、ちょっとぶっ飛ばして80行ってみましょう
ちょっと飛ばして80行ってみよう！
はっはっはっはっはは
はい、というわけで80本でございます
そろそろ、ただの火事になってきました。。。
80歳はたぶん俺はね、ギリ祝えると思ってるんで
多分これはいけるとおもいます！
♪～
やばいやばいやばい
やばいやばいやばいやばい
火が完全におかしいのあるし
一本だけ
まってほんとにまって！
そろそろ誕生日じゃなくなってきてる
まって、結構マジでやばい
熱い熱い
（咳払い）ちょっと。。。
Happy Birthday Dear はじめん～♪
Happy Birthday to you
ッフーーー！！！！！！！！！
っしゃ！まって
まじ火事
ちょっと煙が勝手におかしくなった
よしよしよしよし
80歳でやるとちょっと火事っぽくなりますね
あとケーキが食べれなくなります。
ここまでロウが溶けると。。。
いよいよ大台に入ります！！
次は！100歳でございます！！！！！！
よーっし！！！
はい！100本刺さりました！
もう、ちょっと薄汚いですね
ちょっと、祝ってもらえてる感がなくなってきました
100歳まで生きれると結構長生きだなって
僕の中ではイメージあるんで
ここを乗り切れば、まあ、ひとまず安心かなと思っております
100歳になりました
えー、これからもよろしくお願い致します。
♪～
んんんんんんん？
火事！火事！！まって
ちょっと完全におかしいでしょ
ちょ、まってまって
もう。。。
ねえ！
まって！やばい
あっ。。。ヤバッ
Happy Birthday to you♪～
Happy　Birthday Dear はじめ♪～
っはーー（息吸う）
ッッフーーーー！！！！！！！！！！！！！
火事だぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
♪~ED~♪